Là, j’étais à l’Aiguille du Midi,
au-dessus de Chamonix, dans les Alpes.
Et là, au Rocher des Aigles, dans le Périgord.
Et ça, c’était pour un tournage sur les flamants roses.
Ça fait toujours plaisir de revoir
des photos de vacances ou de voyage.
Je ne sais pas où vous rangez les vôtres,
mais je suppose que, comme beaucoup,
vous les stockez sur un disque dur
comme celui-ci.
Sauf que, j'en ai parlé avec Michaël de la chaîne Micode.
Il a un peu la dent dure
avec les disques durs externes.
On vous explique tout ça aujourd'hui.
Eh bien oui, je crois qu'aujourd'hui,
je vais briser un mythe.
Non, le disque dur n'est
pas un outil fiable pour conserver
nos fichiers intacts sur le long terme.
Et je sens que, derrière leurs écrans,
certains d'entre vous font la grimace.
Pourtant, c'est la vérité.
Pour comprendre pourquoi un disque dur
a une durée de vie moyenne assez courte,
il faut commencer par le commencement.
Un disque dur, ça fonctionne comment ?
Un disque dur se compose d'un ensemble de plateaux.
Ils peuvent être en aluminium,
en verre ou en céramique.
Mais ce ne sont pas ces matériaux
qui abritent directement les données,
ce sont les couches ferromagnétiques
qui les recouvrent.
Ce sont des couches qui permettent
l'enregistrement des informations codées
Mais pour écrire sur la surface d'un
disque, il faut un élément supplémentaire :
une tête d'écriture
qui fait aussi office de tête de lecture.
Ce sont des électroaimants capables
de créer un champ magnétique
positif ou négatif.
On appelle ça la polarisation magnétique.
En fonction du sens de l'aimant,
la tête d'écriture code la surface
du plateau : 0 ou 1.
Elle commence par l'extérieur, en périphérie, pour aller vers le centre du disque.
L'opération effectuée par la tête
d'écriture, d'apparence simple,
est en réalité très complexe.
Le plateau d'un disque,
qu'on appelle aussi galette,
a une importante densité de stockage.
Les têtes de lecture et d'écriture
doivent donc être extrêmement précises.
Elles survolent le plateau
à une distance de l'ordre du nanomètre,
12000 fois plus petit qu'un cheveu.
À la moindre poussière
ou au moindre petit choc,
la tête de lecture se colle à la galette
par adhésion moléculaire, elle se raye
et votre disque est foutu
et vous pouvez dire adieu à vos données.
Le fonctionnement d'un disque dur,
c'est une prouesse technologique,
un petit miracle.
Franck Laloë, directeur de recherche
émérite au CNRS, compare
la distance de survol
d'une tête de lecture à un Concorde
lancé à pleine vitesse,
à seulement 1m du sol.
Cette association
entre des éléments mécaniques
d'un côté et une vitesse de rotation
très élevée de l'autre,
rend les disques durs vraiment fragiles.
Pour l'anecdote,
chez un hébergeur de données,
on avait demandé de toujours
déplacer les disques durs horizontalement
plutôt que verticalement.
Ça permet de
minimiser le risque de saut
de la tête de lecture.
C'est vrai qu'un accident est vite arrivé.
Le disque dur vous échappe des mains
et bim, vous perdez tous vos fichiers.
J'en parle en connaissance de cause.
Comme ils sont fragiles,
les disques durs ont une durée de vie
qui n'excède pas 5 à 7 ans en moyenne.
Bien sûr,
ils peuvent durer plus longtemps,
mais il faut vraiment être très,
très précautionneux.
Heureusement, vous allez le voir,
il existe des alternatives aux disques
durs pour conserver vos données.
Commençons par les SSD.
Solid State Drive, ce sont les successeurs
directs des disques à plateaux.
Ce sont eux qui équipent
très souvent nos ordinateurs aujourd'hui.
Ils embarquent ce qu'on
appelle de la mémoire flash.
Elle est aussi utilisée
dans les cartes mémoires de nos appareils
photo, dans les clés USB,
et on comprend vite pourquoi.
Une grande résistance aux chocs,
aucun élément mécanique
n'entre en jeu, plus rapide et davantage
miniaturisable.
La mémoire flash est construite
avec des transistors,
composants de base de l'informatique
moderne, ayant la capacité d'y piéger
des électrons.
Ainsi, cet amas d'électrons
permet de stocker une valeur binaire.
Pourtant, la mémoire
flash n'est pas la solution idéale,
elle est un peu plus chère, même si ça
tend à se réduire depuis quelques années.
Et surtout, ces transistors
utilisent un composé chimique,
le dioxyde de silicium,
à la durée de vie limitée.
On estime pouvoir réécrire sur une mémoire
flash 100000 fois.
Ça peut paraître beaucoup dit comme ça,
mais ça correspond environ à une dizaine
d'années en usage classique.
Il vaut mieux ne pas
l'oublier dans un placard non plus.
Si elle n'est pas utilisée
une fois de temps en temps,
elle risque de ne plus fonctionner du tout
à cause de ce fichu dioxyde de silicium.
Certains parmi vous
vont peut-être se dire "Dans ce cas, autant
utiliser un bon vieux CD-ROM !
Avec eux, au moins, les informations
sont sauvegardées pour l'éternité."
Sauf que là encore,
c'est une très mauvaise idée.
Je dirais même plus : cette idée
est très très mauvaise.
Dans les années 80,
c'était la bonne solution.
Contrairement aux galettes d'un disque
dur, le CD n'est en contact avec rien.
C'est un laser qui vient lire une fine
couche d'aluminium.
Son système est très ingénieux.
Il est fait de creux
et de bosses invisibles à nos yeux,
grâce auxquels les 0 et les 1 sont stockés.
Le tout couronné
d'un gros succès commercial.
Bref, tout semblait parfait.
On se voyait déjà sauvegarder
nos archives nationales dessus.
Sauf qu'en 2003, on découvre des pertes
d'informations dans certains CD-ROM.
On appelle ce phénomène
le CD-ROT, ou la pourriture du CD.
Des petits points microscopiques
se forment à la surface du disque.
Ce sont des particules oxydées.
Elles viennent percer la couche
d'aluminium contenant les informations.
La lumière du laser ne peut donc plus
se réfléchir sur cette couche d'alu.
Les données sont perdues.
Phénomène accru lors d'une exposition à
la lumière et à des températures élevées.
On le pensait increvable
et pourtant, le CD ou le DVD ne sont pas
des outils de stockage sûrs à long terme.
Jamy, tu connais sans doute
ce dicton : c’est dans les vieux pots
qu’on fait les meilleures confitures ?
J'adore la confiture !
Alors, je vais te parler
d'un moyen de stockage vieux comme
le monde qui a été inventé à une époque
où toi et moi n'étions pas nés.
Le microfilm.
Il s'agit d'un film photographique
contenant des reproductions
de documents au format très réduit.
Vous savez, les pellicules
qu'on utilise en photo argentique ?
Et bien c'est la même chose,
mais en tout petit.
Le microfilm a été inventé
par René Dagron, un photographe
et inventeur français, en 1859,
bien avant l'ère du numérique.
C'est l'un des tout premiers supports
de stockage de documents utilisés
par les entreprises, spécialement
aux États-Unis, où il fait un tabac.
À Salt Lake City, dans l'Utah les mormons
les ont utilisés pendant plus de 80 ans
pour stocker les états civils
des populations de plus de 200 pays.
Mais le microfilm a aussi ses limites.
Au début des années 2000, on constate
en effet que les bandes ont tendance
à gondoler et que des taches brunâtres
se forment sur le support.
Ce film est recouvert
d'une fine couche constituée
d'un mélange homogène de cellulose
et d'acide acétique.
Avec le temps,
ces deux composants se séparent
pour redonner d'un côté de la cellulose
et de l'autre de l'acide acétique.
Ce dernier a tendance à s'évaporer.
Le film se rétracte, il ondule,
ce qui provoque la perte d'informations.
Ce phénomène a été baptisé
"syndrome du vinaigre", tout simplement
parce que les bandes
sentaient le vinaigre.
Et pour cause, l'acide acétique,
c'est du vinaigre.
De grandes bibliothèques
d'archives, comme l'Institut
national de l'audiovisuel : l'INA en France
ou encore la TSR : Télévision suisse
romande, ont dû entreprendre
un grand plan de numérisation
de toutes leurs bobines de films.
La TSR a recensé des milliers de bobines
touchées par le syndrome du vinaigre.
Et les mormons,
dont tu nous a parlé tout à l'heure,
ont fait exactement la même chose.
En 2021, ils ont annoncé avoir terminé
la numérisation de tous leurs microfilms.
Ça leur a quand même pris 25 ans.
Il n'empêche que l'idée du microfilm
pour conserver des données
dans le temps n'est
pas du tout mauvaise, Jamy.
La bande magnétique,
reste ce qu'il y a de plus efficace.
Encore faut-il trouver un moyen
de les conserver dans le temps.
C'est la question que l'on s'est posée à l'INA,
mais aussi au CERN, l'Organisation
pour la recherche nucléaire.
C'est l'organisme
qui exploite le fameux LHC,
le plus grand accélérateur de particules
au monde,
situé à la frontière entre la Suisse
et la France.
Il se trouve que les expérimentations
du CERN génèrent
une quantité astronomique de données
qu'il n'est pas envisageable de perdre.
En un mois, le LHC génère
plus de 12 pétaoctets de données brutes.
C’est l’équivalent
de la mémoire de 200000 smartphones.
Elles sont stockées sur des disques durs
dans un premier temps
pour être traitées avant d'être archivées.
D'après un rapport interne, en 2020,
les archives du CERN
comptent 320 pétaoctets de données.
De quoi enregistrer
une vidéo HD pendant 1000 ans.
Pour conserver et consulter cet amas
considérable d'informations,
le CERN a fait un choix :
la bonne vieille bande magnétique.
Mais sous une forme assez particulière,
le LTO pour "linear tape open".
C'est une cartouche de plastique,
comme un jeu de Game Boy, qui contient
une bande magnétique.
C'est résistant aux chocs,
ça ne consomme pas d'électricité,
c'est bien plus fiable
qu'un disque dur de l'ordre de 1000 fois.
C'est une technologie encore en évolution.
Une seule cartouche pourrait atteindre
une capacité de 50
téraoctets dans le futur.
Et ce n'est pas si cher que ça.
Une cinquantaine d'euros
la cartouche de six téraoctets.
À l'heure actuelle,
on considère que c'est la solution ultime
pour l'archivage de données.
Le CERN en possède
plus de 50000 gérés par des robots.
Seul bémol,
le prix d'un lecteur de cartouches LTO :
plusieurs milliers d'euros.
Aïe, ça refroidit...
Peut-on faire mieux que la bande
magnétique pour archiver nos données ?
Pour le moment, la réponse est non.
Mais un nouveau support
tout à fait étonnant est à l'étude.
Il se cache ici au cœur de nos cellules.
Je parle de l'ADN.
Avec l'accélération et la baisse des coûts
permettant la synthèse
et le séquençage de l'ADN, nous arriverons
peut-être bientôt
à utiliser de l'ADN synthétique
pour stocker nos photos de vacances.
Un seul gramme d'ADN
peut contenir des centaines de pétaoctets.
Pour info, un pétaoctet correspond
à 1 million de gigas.
Imaginez que l'ensemble des informations
contenues sur Internet pourraient
tenir sur un support
grand comme une tablette de chocolat.
D'ailleurs, l'INA, l'Institut
national de l'audiovisuel, s'intéresse
de très près à cet outil du futur
pour conserver nos archives.
Et Michaël, ton équipe a elle-même fait
l'expérience avec l'Institut Pasteur,
vous avez réussi à stocker
de l'information sur l'ADN.
Je me souviens,
j'étais sur le plateau de l'émission.
Très impressionnant !
Eh oui, Jamy, on peut dire
que nous sommes des pionniers.
En revanche, c'est une opération
encore trop coûteuse et trop longue
pour le moment. Une autre méthode
est à l'étude : le stockage
dans du quartz, matériau
très très résistant et stable.
Sa durée de vie est estimée entre 300
millions et plusieurs milliards d'années.
L'idée est simple : à l'aide
d'un laser, on vient graver
de l'information à l'intérieur du quartz,
à l'abri des poussières ou des rayures
pouvant survenir en surface.
Et pour le lire,
un simple microscope suffit.
C'est passionnant,
mais ces solutions sont expérimentales
ou bien elles sont hors de prix.
Du coup, on fait comment
pour protéger nos photos de vacances ?
La solution tient en une expression :
ne pas mettre tous ses œufs
dans le même panier.
Une donnée bien sauvegardée
est une donnée stockée sur différents
supports et dans différents lieux.
Ça peut être chez un ami par exemple, ou
encore plus simple, à l'aide d'un drive.
Ces espaces de stockage en ligne
dans le cloud, comme on dit souvent,
sont hébergés dans de grands datacenters.
Dans ces systèmes de drive,
nos données sont automatiquement
répliquées sur différents disques durs
et dans différents lieux pour prévenir
tout accident et perte de données.
Vous n'avez rien à faire,
tout est automatique, alors pourquoi pas
y stocker quelques photos ?
Que ce soit gratuitement
pour une faible quantité de données
ou en payant un abonnement
pour un espace plus important.
Malgré son prix plus élevé,
si le drive est autant plébiscité,
c'est bien pour sa simplicité d'utilisation
et la tranquillité d'esprit qui va avec.
- Merci Michaël !
Merci à vous toutes et tous d'avoir
suivi cette vidéo jusqu'à son terme.
Alors je sais, ça fait beaucoup d'infos,
mais l'avantage avec YouTube, c'est
que si vous avez un problème de mémoire,
vous pouvez revisionner la vidéo
autant de fois que vous le voulez.
Allez, bonne semaine et à dimanche prochain pour une nouvelle vidéo épicurieuse !